vous connaissez laurent baffie vous
c'est un type que j'ai rencontré ya
quinze jours qui me fait mourir de rire
alors bas j'ai décidé de lui confier une
séquence laurent baffie le bâti chaud
c'est dégueulasse ouais parce que moi
j'ai dire un truc je suis propre c'est
neuf ça vous êtes donc peace and love
peace and love for her pas en même temps
si tout est tous en même temps
mais bon pas trop exagérer non plus je
ne savais pas que les pales - servait à
faire des smokings mais considère que le
mâle correspond à la taille 6 ans et la
femelle à la taille 4 ans c'est un baby
gros sur mesure ça mais c'est ce qu'on a
eu effectivement c'est la même chose que
les phoques
puis la mode va passer quand ça va être
passée on va changer vous pensez que la
mode des phoques va passer bien sûr
gérant c'est que pascal sevran va être
amenée à disparaître bien sûr tout ça ça
va il n'y a pas de présent
personnellement vous avez déjà porté des
fourrures
non ainsi j'ai porté ça mais c'est du
cdu c'est du factice appelant sur les
bouts de sang factice de monsieur aider
factice combien de bébés factice doit-on
tuer pour faire confectionner une perte
de ces bourses ne le sais pas moi-même
et elles me font moins de 2,2 au mois
deux bébés dont vous cautionnez le
massacre des bébés factice pour
confectionner des buttes
oui pardon monsieur qui pensez vous donc
les gens qui massacrent des branques
téléphoner vous mais ces trente secondes
1 leur couper la tête aux pingouins
non non aux gens qui tuent couvrent la
tête ou pas moi c'est une épaule de quoi
je suis pas du tout voir l'école s'il
vous plaît étiquette
j'ai passé
je crois que c'est du lézard vous savez
vous-même un col en fourrure c'est du
synthétique
mais vous avez déjà pensé au regard de
la maman synthétique quand on massacre
devant elle son bébé
non mais
j'imagine les corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus